thank you Mr Speaker I wish to begin by
paying tribute to my friends and
colleagues the right honorable member
for Ross Sky I walk over here
tea for the last five years Mr Speaker
he is a giant of the Scottish
independence movement Mr Speaker not one
two
Prime Ministers indeed he was on to his
fourth and recent weeks into that latest
prime minister I have a very simple
question what does he consider to be the
greatest achievement of the conservative
party in government since 2019 leaving
the single market and Customs Union
ending freedom of movement denying
Scotland to a democracy or getting the
labor party to agree with all of the
above foreign
Mr Speaker can I start by offering my
genuine and warm heartfelt best wishes
to the right honorable member for Ross
guy in locado
I know I know the whole house will miss
his weekly contributions
and they and may I may I also
congratulate or join the first minister
in congratulating The Honorable
Gentleman on his appointment as a
Westminster leader of the SMP I look
forward to a constructive debate with
him across the dispatch box and Mr
Speaker the answer to this question is
actually very simple for things that we
are most proud of in the last couple of
years is making sure that we protected
this country through the pandemic with
with furlough and with the fastest
vaccine roll out
Mr Speaker for me to offer advice to a
near billionaire but he's going to have
to up his game and here's why because in
the last 15 minutes a poll has landed
which shows the support for Scottish
independence has now hit 56 percent
50 so in that context can I ask the
Prime Minister does he consider that
increasing energy bills on households
and energy rich Scotland by a further
500 pounds will cause those poll numbers
to rise or to fall
well Mr Speaker what we're delivering
for households across the United Kingdom
including those in Scotland is 55
billion pounds of support with energy
bills it will save a typical homeowner
about 900 pounds under their bills this
winter with extra support for the most
vulnerable and that is Mr Speaker an
example of the United Kingdom and the
union delivering for people in Scotland